do you think Larry David who's also in
there dressed as a nun also had trouble
letting go of that we mentioned clothes
make the man yeah think that worked for
him in that case man you know he uh
wasn't like working with the guy oh come
on he's the greatest and he's uh he's a
big stooge he's a stooge fan and him and
Pete fairly are good friends and then
but then Larry David has to show up and
hang out with us for a couple weeks he's
like I didn't realize it was going to
take this long you know but uh ah [ __ ] I
gotta be out here in Atlanta it's
boiling hot but at one point uh there's
this line where he kept doing a he would
just spit a different line every time he
was like getting hit in the head with
somebody's laying there on the ground
and he goes he like comes to and he says
at one point he goes
Miami audiences are the best audiences
in the world right and because he's
loopy now he's playing a nun at the at
the orphanage where the Three Stooges
grew up and I'm super intimidated by
Larry David he's a genius and stuff and
and uh and but I walk up to him and I go
uh so he's what is he like a
like a borsche belt Florida comedian who
is on the lamb and so he's dressing as a
woman he ends up at an orphanage like
what's going on there and he just and he
looks at me just goes
yeah
like
I'm like yeah he's got some like actor
motivation like yeah of course he looks
it's Larry David in a nuns habit which
is hilarious that's such a fairly
casting thing it's you know and he's but
he's doing this whole like what a warm
audience you know like like oh he's like
this cat skill comedian who's been
living in you know so that's what he was
like living through in his mind is just
having fun with it right I mean that and
probably a combination of that and
getting the lines right because he's
like what are we doing here what is you
know just frustrated all day with what
the heck we're trying to do what do you
think makes I mean that guy is one of
the best improv people ever yeah so what
do you think makes him so good like what
why is it so compelling
to watch that guy because he's a comedic
genius like he literally he knows what
he does he's been a writer for 50 years
or whatever and he's and he just happens
to be that brilliant I mean I've gotten
a chance just to do I did it uh just an
episode of curb a small part and
it's crazy what he sees I don't know
what he sees as a matter of fact
so I auditioned for it for curb like you
know two or three times right and never
got anything and then uh it was only
after working with him on the Stooges I
got a call to do a bid part
but I remember auditioning you go into
that into that room and the guys waiting
are all people that you know you're like
oh I know them I know her I know him and
uh
so I went in I auditioned for this for
this part and um
the only thing I know the thing is like
okay so you really want to go to this
play with me you really want to go to
this plane when you hear that I have an
extra ticket
you sincerely want to think and I'm like
got it and so that's the premise the
premise of the scene and that's all you
know it's all I know and so he goes he
does his bit and I'm just supposed to
come in and interrupt and I'm like
excuse me
I couldn't help but here you guys were
talking about you know whatever the play
was or you know Death of a Salesman I am
I'm a huge fan of that play I mean if
it's not if it's not if you're looking
for someone to take a ticket I I would
love to go my name's so and so by the
way and he goes I'm going to stop you
I'm gonna stop you and I'm like he goes
are you really you I mean you truly want
to go to this play and I go yes yes sir
you really want to go you actually this
is you would love to do this I go okay
let's try it again so then he's like no
no and I go hey uh excuse me I'm sorry I
don't mean to interrupt I was just I I
couldn't help it over here you have uh
tickets to the thing I am the biggest
fan I do the same thing I'm going to
stop you again okay
I mean you really want to go and I'm
just like he's [ __ ] with me right
yeah I remember Jeff Garland was sitting
there in the audition he goes he did it
he said it what shut up no hold on
listen you really want to go okay three
or four times you know there I am I
couldn't help but notice it and then I
do it again I guess I [ __ ] the bed
because he looks at me he just goes okay
all right okay well
thanks for coming up and that was it and
I didn't get it so I still I don't know
what the heck that guy's thinking he
sees
he's in The Matrix I don't know what the
heck Larry David sees you know what I
mean he wanted what some kind of more
desperation or something like this like
he wanted a level of sincerity that I
sent that I that I I was bringing and I
guess I was wrong I don't know maybe go
crazy like what does it mean to really
want yeah I should have grabbed him by
the Scruff of the neck and go yeah
listen dad you're bringing me this
[ __ ] play I would have got the part
as a matter of fact I heard about
someone else
and I don't know who the heck this was
I forget who it was but I've heard this
story from a couple different people
that there's this actor and I can't I
don't remember who it was if I did I
probably wouldn't say it out loud anyway
but he wrapped it it was Brad Pitt and
he was in this audition and he was and
there was out in the hall he's like holy
[ __ ] George Clooney Leo DiCaprio
um and he this actor went in and he did
the thing and um Larry David was like
hey why don't you try it again and he
got like a couple takes in and he went I
don't think this is for me and he left
which an actor never does yeah and as
The Story Goes Larry David shouted after
him I respect that
which I think is true and I want to
believe that entire story is true yeah
yeah sounds like something Larry David
made up at the top Bobby Lee told me
that story so we can't